the senate will come to order and the
chaplain dr barry black will lead us in
prayer
let us pray sovereign
king our hope for years to come
deliver us from the sin
of running from the truth
remind us often that
truth brings freedom
thank you that you are our helper
sustaining our lives and
keeping us strong
you guide us through the wilderness
and protect us through life's
storms lord
inspire our lawmakers
to place themselves into your hands
permitting you to fulfill your purposes
through their faithful toil
fill them with reverential
awe and give them
a sanctified audacity
even when facing trials
and setbacks we pray
in your loving name
amen
liberty
we actually started a minute before
um
you
you
uh
mr president pro tem the majority leader
senator from vermont
majority leader is recognized the
senator from new york
now mr president it came to our
attention last night
that members of the national guard after
standing on duty to protect the capital
for inauguration day keeping us safe
we're sleeping in parking garages and
cramped quarters
without proper space or ventilation
it is it was utterly unacceptable
i have told those who run the security
of the capitol that it can
never happen again and i pledge to every
national guard member that it will not
happen again
the minute i heard about this outrage
last
night we made sure it was fixed
immediately every member of the guard
was found proper accommodations inside
and as of this morning everyone was
accounted for and taken care of
this morning i went over to the cvc
and i spoke to a number of guardsmen
personally to make sure they were okay
i want to thank senators hassan
duckworth kelly and heinrich
for their work on this matter last night
as well
as senator lujan who went
around late at night to make sure things
were okay as well
and i want to thank all the members who
were concerned and lent a hand
i also want to particularly thank acting
sergeant-at-arms jennifer hemingway
who when we told her about this
situation
patrolled the floors of the capitol
complex until past 3 a.m
to ensure that no one was left behind or
not where they belonged
and she was back at her desk first thing
today to follow up
we owe an enormous debt of gratitude to
the men and women who work to keep us
safe on january 6 in the days since
a situation like last night will never
happen again
now i've spoken about the senate's
agenda for the next several weeks
we have three essential items on our
plate
one the confirmation of president
biden's cabinet and other key officials
two legislation to provide desperately
needed covert relief
three a second impeachment trial of
donald trump
the senate must and will do all three
relief confirmation of nominees
and impeachment trial now the first
order of business is to
fulfill our constitutional duty to
advise and consent
on the president's appointments to his
cabinet
this morning the senate will vote to
confirm
president biden's nominee for secretary
of defense
lloyd austin mr austin will be the first
african american
to ever helm the defense department in
its history
a powerful symbol of the diversity and
history
of america's armed forces mr austin has
a storied career in the army but those
days are behind him
as secretary of defense he promised to
empower and lift up his civilian staff
and i believe he will be an outstanding
secretary of defense for everyone at the
pentagon
service members and civilian employees
alike
the secretary of defense of course has a
hugely important task ahead of him
he must once again demonstrate to the
world that the u.s military will always
support our friends
deter our adversaries and if necessary
defeat them
lloyd austin is the right person for the
job
he has the experience the vision and the
competence
to run the largest agency in our
government i look forward
to confirming his nomination shortly
afterwards the senate must continue to
install president biden's team
by confirming secretaries of state
homeland security and treasury
we need republican cooperation to
confirm these nominees
but we expect that cooperation to
continue
the continuity of our national security
military and
intelligence policy as well as our
ability to effectively respond to the
current health and economic crises
depend on having these cabinet officials
confirmed
now as i mentioned the senate will also
conduct a second
impeachment trial for donald trump i've
been speaking to the republican leader
about the timing and duration of the
trial but make no mistake
a trial will be held in the united
states senate and there will be a vote
on whether to convict the president
i've spoken to speaker pelosi who
informed me
that the articles will be delivered to
the senate on monday
now i've heard some of my republican
colleagues argue
that this trial would be
unconstitutional because donald trump is
no longer in office
an argument that has been roundly
repudiated debunked
by hundreds of constitutional scholars
left right and center
and defies basic common sense it makes
no sense whatsoever
that a president or any official could
commit a heinous crime against our
country
and then be permitted to resign so as to
avoid accountability and a vote to
disbar them
from future office makes no sense
regardless the purveyors of this unusual
argument
are trying to delay the inevitable the
fact is the house will deliver the
article of impeachment to the senate
the senate will conduct a trial of the
impeachment of donald trump
it will be a full trial it will be a
fair trial
but make no mistake there will be a
trial and when that trial ends
senators will have to decide if they
believe
donald john donald john trump incited
the erection
insurrection against the united states
now over the course of of elections in
november and january
the american people chose to retire four
republican senators and elect a
democratic majority to this senate
the senate must now take the basic step
of passing an organizing resolution
and setting up the rules for it for a
senate where there are 50 members of
either party
luckily we have a clear precedent for
what to do in this
situation in 2001
then majority leader lot and minority
leader daschle
came together and agreed on a set of
rules to govern a 50-50 senate
we should follow that precedent we have
offered to abide by the same agreement
the last time there was a 50 50 senate
what's fair is fair that is precedent
we could organize the senate today if
both sides agreed to abide by the same
rules as last time
the republican leader however has made
an extraneous demand that would place
additional constraints on the majority
constraints that have never been in
place before
in fact his proposal would remove a tool
that the republican leader himself
used twice in just the last congress
to accelerate the confirmation of
republican nominees
leader mcconnell's proposal sorry leader
mcconnell's proposal
is unacceptable and it won't be accepted
and the republican leader knew that when
he first proposed it
only two days ago mr president we
celebrated the inauguration of a new
president
and the turning over of a new leaf the
american people want us to work together
and move past the meaningless political
fights and gridlock that have plagued us
for too long
it's time to get to work the first step
is for the republican caucus to agree to
follow the same precedent that governed
the senate
last time around i yield the floor
mr president republican leader
yesterday evening we learned that some
of the national guard forces
who've been helping protect the capitol
complex
were being made to rest in parking
garages between their ships
i don't think a single senator feels
that was acceptable
i'm glad the situation was resolved and
i hope we learn exactly
what happened in that regard i want to
thank all the national guard including
more than 300 kentucky guardsmen
and local and federal law enforcement
who've helped supplement
our very own capitol police in the wake
of january the 6th
your congress and your country
appreciate all you've done to secure the
capitol
and the inauguration later today i'll
have the honor of meeting a number of my
kentuckians
who've been helping out here at the
capitol is going to be the highlight
of my day in the near future congress
needs to smartly transition toward a
more sustainable security presence
keeping the capital safe cannot and will
not require huge numbers of uniform
troops
and vast systems of emergency fencing to
remain in place forever
with the inauguration behind us we
should find the right middle ground
between the unacceptable lapses three
weeks ago and the extraordinarily
short-term measures that have been put
in place
since that time in the meantime
we need to make darn sure that we look
after the men and women
who look after us now that's right on a
totally different matter
while business proceeds on the floor the
democratic leader and i are continuing
to flesh out the structure
of this 50-50 senate
when leaders lot daschle wrote a similar
agreement
20 years ago there wasn't a need
at all to reaffirm the basic standing
rules that govern legislation here in
the senate
it was safely assumed that no majority
would break this rule for short-term
gain
floor remarks surrounding those 2001
discussions
specifically cite the legislative
filibuster as an important and
unquestioned
part of the backdrop that lay beneath
the negotiations on the finer
details it was assumed no one
would ever take that step after the fact
leader daschle the democrat praised the
legislative filibuster as a crucial rule
president biden has praised this
distinctive feature of the senate
on many occasions our current democratic
colleagues used it
liberally liberally over the last
several years
when they were in the minority more than
two dozen signed a bipartisan letter in
2017
saying our republican majority should
not break the rule by brute force
let me say that again two dozen
democrats signed a bipartisan letter in
2017 saying our
republican majority should not break
this rule by brute force
i agree i didn't do it
president trump was not happy with that
he tweeted against me numerous times
because i didn't do
put an end to the legislative filibuster
and so the democrats used it constantly
as they had every right to
they were happy to insist on a 60-vote
threshold for practically every major
bill i took up
so we'll continue to request that our
democratic colleagues reaffirm
this standing rule of the senate which
they have been happy
to use on many occasions i can attest
if we're going to truly replicate the
2001 agreement we need to reaffirm this
crucial part of the foundation
that lay beneath it yesterday i also
shared a proposal for the pre-trial
steps in the senate impeachment process
that appears to be headed our way and as
i understand and must be headed our way
monday
now senate rules if the article arrives
we have to start a trial
right then this impeachment began
with an unprecedentedly fast and minimal
process over in the house
the sequel cannot be an insufficient
senate process
that denies former president trump his
due process
or damages the senate or the presidency
itself senate republicans strongly
believe we need a full and fair
process where the former president can
mount a defense
and the senate can properly consider the
factual
legal and constitutional questions at
stake
for that reason we suggest the house
transmits this article next thursday but
that's
apparently going to be next monday that
former president trump's answer and the
house pre-trial
brief i suggested be due on february 4th
and the former president's pre-trial
brief be due i suggested
on february the 11th that timeline would
have provided the senate some more
explore time before we step
up fully into the unknown of a trial
which by the way would have been a
substantial benefit to the incoming
administration
and allowed them to get more of their
cabinet confirmed which we are
cooperating as best we can to expedite
so finally mr president on one final
matter
regarding those nominees we're
considering to president biden's
nominees for key cabinet posts on
wednesday april
haynes was confirmed as director of
national intelligence on a big
bipartisan vote including my own
we hope to be able to consider tony
blanken to be the secretary of state
early next week
today we're considering general lloyd
austin
president bush biden's nominee to be
served as secretary of defense
i voted to approve the waiver that would
allow him to serve in this post
yesterday notwithstanding the seven year
cooling off period
after military service and i'll be
voting in favor of his confirmation
i'm voting yes because the nominee is
clearly qualified and because presidents
should get real attitude to fill their
terms
with qualified mainstream people
of their choosing at the same time the
senate should pause and reflect on the
fact that we'll have begun two
consecutive presidential administrations
by issuing a waiver to a four-star
general and former centcon commander
to lead the pentagon the armed services
committee held a hearing last week to
examine the waiver and the current
state of civil military relations at the
pentagon
i expect the committee will continue to
pay close attention to this important
issue
in the months ahead and will investigate
steps the congress can take to help
restore
balance over at the pentagon
the law that we keep waiving actually
exists for a good reason
civilian control of the military is a
fundamental principle of our republic
we emphatically do not want high-ranking
military service to become
a tested prerequisite for civilian
leadership posts
over the department of defense it's not
just about a simplistic
fear that the military will end up
running itself
to the contrary many experts worry that
military leaders appropriate
fixation on being non-political may not
prepare them for the job
to forcefully fight for armed service
services
amid the political rough and tumble in
the executive branch and here in
congress
put another way they're taught from the
beginning
to stay out of politics entirely
but you do want a secretary of defense
who's willing to engage in the
issue-based discussions that we have
related to the department
so nevertheless i'll vote today to
confirm a clear patriot with an
impressive career
but i'll cast that vote with the
understanding that our new secretary of
defense
specifically commits to balancing civil
military relations
empowering civilian leaders at the
pentagon and playing an active role in
the inherently political budget process
to get our forces
what they need our intensifying
competition with china and russia and
all the other threats we face
demand nothing less
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved
morning business is closed
and under the previous order the senate
will proceed to the executive session to
consider the following nomination which
the clerk will report
nomination department of defense lloyd
james austin of georgia to be secretary
under the previous order there will be
10 minutes of debate equally divided in
the usual form
mr president senator from rhode island
mr president it's my understanding that
chairman inhofe
is in route to provide his
comments and i want to begin by thanking
him for his tremendous leadership
without his dedication to a bipartisan
thoughtful process we would not be here
today and it's a hallmark of his
leadership throughout the years we serve
together
and uh i anticipate his arrival but uh
i will uh in order to expedite the vote
let me proceed
mr further i rise to express my support
for the confirmation of
lloyd austin to be the secretary of
defense of the united states
general austin is an exceptionally
qualified leader with a long and
distinguished career in the united
states military
he served at the highest echelons of the
army and captive service
as the commander of u.s central command
his character and
integrity are unquestioned and he
possesses the knowledge and skill to
effectively lead the pentagon
the united states faces many complex
security threats
if confirmed of the secretary of defense
general austin will lead the department
during a time when u.s strategic
priorities have shifted to focus
increasingly
on near peer competition with china and
russia the department must
also transform how it operates with an
increased focus on
critical technologies like artificial
intelligence quantum computing
biotechnology and cyber security while
also emphasizing
rapid delivery advanced new weapon
systems on timelines that keep pace with
technological change
in addition president biden must address
urgent and dying challenges that
few of us would have anticipated four
years ago our country is in the midst of
a pandemic
that has claimed hundreds of thousands
of lives infected millions more
and resulted in billions of economic
damage and the virus is still not under
control
recently it was revealed that last
segment of the federal government
major companies were hacked by russia we
are still trying to ascertain
the extent of the breach but it could be
the most significant cyber intrusion
in the history of our country the world
this event too
should prompt us to move promptly to
fill cabinet
positions that are critical to our
national security
and unfortunately the department of
defense is adrift and in desperate need
of steadfast leadership
over the course the past four years
there has been repeated turnover at
senior levels of the department
and a concerted effort to purposely
leave multiple senior level
civilian offices unfilled necessity
necessitating the installment of career
or mid-level officials
into positions in an acting capacity
unlike the nominees for cabinet
positions congress must provide as
senator mcconnell
indicated an exception for general
lawson to serve with the secretary of
defense
under the current statutes individuals
are prohibited from appointment if they
are within seven years of the military
service
congress found itself in a similar
situation four years ago when president
trump
nominated general james mattis to be the
secretary of defense
now prior to general austin's
confirmation hearing the senate armed
service committee held a hearing on
civilian control of the armed served
forces
that focused on the erosion of civil
military relations
at the hearing valid concerns were
raised about providing another way or so
soon
after secretary mattis however at his
nomination hearing earlier this week
general austin pledged his commitment to
repairing civilis
military relations while also empowering
the civilian
personnel within the department of
defense these were critical comments
from general austin
and ones that i support therefore
yesterday i voted in favor of the
legislation
to provide general austin with an
exception to serve as a secular defense
and i was pleased the legislation
received strong bipartisan support
generally austin is an outstanding
choice to serve as secular defense
i'm proud to support his nomination
given the unique challenges we face
and mr president i think from now on uh
in a few moments we can refer to him as
secretary austin which is the
appropriate title for his role
with that mr president i yield the floor
to my colleague
and uh the chairman mr stanhope mr
president i
senior senator from oklahoma mr
president yesterday
uh i had the opportunity to respond
to the majority on my support for
tony blankly the secretary of state
he's one that i've known for a long
period of time and i
and uh i think that we'll see with the
new administration here as
myself being a conservative republican
and and uh
there'll be some of the appointments
that i will not will not
really get excited about and agree with
in which case i will
state it but in the case of the
secretary of state i
expressed myself yesterday and i want to
do it again today
for the what i consider to be the really
critical
first appointment uh second appointment
that the new administration makes
and that would be for general austin to
be the
the the person in charge at a time
that's very unique and i agree with the
senator who just spoke
about the qualities of this general we
know that he's been
he rose to the ranks to the army to
become the first for
become the four star general commander
of the central command
from 2013 to 2016. he's done everything
right
we right now and i know the chair is
aware of this and certainly
the the ranking member of the committee
is aware of this we're in the most
threatened times that we've been
we have china and russia out there with
capabilities that we
didn't really believe we would find
ourselves with
so that's going to be the primary
concern of this
new administration and i can't think of
a better person to take the
the the uh the helm uh
than general austin to provide the
leadership
and it's true that we had to have a
waiver yesterday that waver was
overwhelmingly
supported in a bipartisan way and
so everyone knows that we gave a lot of
thought to it
and this is a time when we really needed
someone with the
background of general austin to take
that position
and i strongly support it and look
forward to serving with them
under the previous uh order the question
uh
of the nomination occurs on the
nomination
is there a yeas is affirmative
gays and nays daisy neisman
appears to be clerk will call the role
ms baldwin mr barrasso mr bennett mrs
blackburn mr blumenthal
mr blunt mr booker mr bozeman mr braun
mr brown mr burr miss cantwell
this is capitao
mr cardin
oh thank she's you
thank you i got you
thank you
mr cardin mr carper mr casey
mr cassidy ms collins
mr coons
mr cornyn miss cortez masto
mr cotton mr cramer
mr crapo mr cruz
mr danes ms duckworth
mr durbin ms ernst
mrs feinstein this is fisher
this is gillibrand
thank you mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
miss hassan mr hawley
mr heinrich mr hickenlooper
ms hirono mr hoeven
mrs hyde-smith mr inhofe
mr johnson mr kane
mr kelly mr kennedy
mr king ms klobuchar
mr lankford mr leahy
mr lee mr lujan
ms lomas
mr mansion mr markey
mr marshall mr mcconnell
mr menendez mr merkley
mr moran miss murkowski
mr murphy mrs murray
straussoff
mr padilla mr paul
mr peters mr portman
mr reed
mr risch mr romney
ms rosen mr rounds
mr rubio mr
sanders mr sass
mr schatz mr schumer
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
thank you
take care miss cinema
ms smith ms stavenow
mr sullivan
mr tester mr thune
[Music]
mr tillis mr
toomey
mr tuberville mr van hollen
mr warner mr warnock
ms warren mr whitehouse
mr wicker mr wyden
mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
blumenthal
brown cantwell carper
casey cassidy cornyn
cotton cramer danes
durbin ernst grassley
heinrich inhofe king
lankford mansion reed
scott of florida shaheen and white house
no senator voted in the negative
mr wyden i
mr leahy i
mr kelly i
mr risch
i mr portman
i miss collins
aye mr chester
aye
mr hickenlooper i
miss smith i
mr tuberville i
mr padilla i ms stabenow
aye mr kane i mr paul
i
mr mcconnell i
mr bennett i
mr lee no
mr warner i
mrs feinstein i mr rubio
i
mrs murray i
you
mr murky i
thank you
mr braun aye mr coons
thank you mr marshall
i miss llamas
i mr coons
i mr hawley
no mr rounds
i
mr johnson i
mr cardin i
uh
mr booker i
mr sanders i
mr peters i
mr warnock i
mr van hollen i
miss rosen i
mr barrasso i
mr kennedy i
mr romney aye
mr ossoff i
mr wicker i
miss baldwin i mrs fisher
i confirmed
i
miss cinema i
mrs gillibrand i mr young
i
mr shots i
mr hagerty i
mr menendez i
mr shelby i
mr sass i
mr graham i
that's
mr crapo i
mr luhan aye
thank you
mr blunt i
mr scott of south carolina i mr toomey
aye
so
mr boseman i
miss warren i
miss murkowski i
schumer i
mrs blackburn i
miss cortes masto i
mr merkley i
so
mr soon i
mr murphy i
you
mr sullivan i
miss klobuchar
miss klobuchar i
you
i
mr cruz i
you
this
you
mr hovind i
so wishing to vote or change your vote
okay right now
are there any senators wishing to vote
or change their vote
if not the yeas are 93 the nays are two
and the nomination
is confirmed under the previous order
the motion to reconsider is considered
made and laid upon the table
and the president will be immediately
notified of the senate's actions
senator from oregon is recognized madam
president
i'm having a little trouble hearing
madam president please take your
conversations outside the senate will
come to order
senator from oregon is recognized thank
you madam president first i ask
unanimous consent
that the senate be in a period of
mourning business
with senators permitted to speak therein
for up to 10 minutes each
madam president i have one request
for committees to meet during today's
session
of the senate they have the approval
of the majority and the minority
duly noted madam president
a few minutes ago chair janet yellen was
approved by the senate finance committee
to be the secretary of treasury
by an extraordinary 26
to zero vote i have seen
times around here in the senate
where you come away convinced you
couldn't get
26 to nothing among senators to buy
a soda and i want to
thank senators grassley
and krepo for working very
closely the senate will come to order
thank you madam president i want to
thank senators grassley
and crapo for working very closely
with me and senate democrats
to achieve this remarkable vote this
morning
the fact is janet yellen has been
confirmed
by this body four times
she really belongs in the senate
confirmation hall of fame
and the reason that she's been confirmed
all of these times is
because of what we saw at her
confirmation hearing
on tuesday she did a superb
job after the hearing
she responded to hundreds of questions
in a substantive way that came
from colleagues and has made a real
commitment
to transparency now i know that
senators are working on a variety of
issues now but i would like
to say that i think given the
urgency of the economic challenge
our country faces in a truly
perilous economic time
i would very much like to work with all
of my colleagues
particularly senators crepo
and grassley center of crapo on the
floor
to find a way to today
bring up chair yellen for confirmation
to be
our secretary of treasury and i want to
say i
very much appreciate the conciliatory
way
this was discussed today
and i really hope that the senate can
vote on her nomination today
madam president i yield the floor
the senator from arkansas is recognized
madam president i asked consent that at
the end of my remarks the senator from
oklahoma
senator inhofe be recognized without
objection
consent that is the conclusion of the
remarks of the senator from arkansas
that i be recognized
without objection
madam president on wednesday just
moments after joe biden took office
china's ministry of foreign affairs
sanctioned 28 members
of the outgoing administration including
secretary of state mike pompeo
national security adviser robert o'brien
and un ambassador kelly kraft
according to chinese state media these
trump administration officials were
guilty of
quote crazy moves which gravely
interfered
in china's internal affairs crazy crazy
moves
include presumably condemning the
chinese communist party's
genocidal campaign against religious
minorities in xinjiang province
or its atheistic crackdown on chinese
christians
in addition to interfering these alleged
these officials allegedly offended the
chinese people
and seriously disrupted u.s china
relations
i guess that refers to some such as
secretary of health and human services
alex azar
who traveled to taiwan under the new
sanctions these officials are now barred
from entering china
but more important and more ominous
institutions associated with them are
also restricted from doing business with
china
now it's tempting to laugh off these
sanctions as i did last summer when
china sanctioned me
you know you know you won't have a
second honeymoon in wuhan
or you'll have to vacation in a
non-genocidal
country but these sanctions are no
laughing matter
they're not bluster they're another step
in china's long-term campaign to coerce
americans at every
level of government and business they
are a direct attack
on the independence of u.s policy toward
china and an attempt to blackmail the
biden administration
with personal financial ruin in the
future
if they dare to stand up to the chinese
communist party
some may start to think about the
potential damage to their future and
they may start to sweat a little bit
now you may say good i'm glad that
former government officials
can't cash in on their service and go to
influence peddling firms like
west exec or albright stone ridge
and sell access to chinese i might even
agree with that point
but consider a few other hypotheticals
the chinese state media singled out book
publishers
as just one example of who could pay the
price many public officials
like to write memoirs and these memoirs
often add a lot to our understanding of
current events
but chinese state media singled out book
publishers
as an example of companies that would be
banned from china
if they associated with sanctioned
individuals
and in fact china has already used
american books as pawns in the trade war
with the united states so will major
publishing houses really risk losing
access to the chinese market for all
their other titles to strike a book deal
with say
a former biden cabinet official who was
tough on china
and ended up getting sanctioned it's
unclear but i would say doubtful
other public officials practice at big
law firms
and i know that we all make jokes about
lawyers
but it's an honorable profession and
there's nothing wrong with practicing at
a big law firm and they may plan to
return to their firms after the
administration
is over a lot of those firms have
close or client clients with close ties
to china
and even if a former public official has
no client with any business
in china will those law firms
really take back their old employees if
it means potentially losing valuable
clients who are afraid of
angering the chinese communist party
again i'd say it's unclear
but perhaps doubtful once you consider
these hypotheticals and
others that don't involve influence
peddling or anything
untoward you can begin to see the
insidious consequences of these new
sanctions
beijing wants to scare the abideth
administration into doing its bidding
and they want to scare us businesses
into blacklisting any official
who irritates the chinese communist
party
therefore i call on the biden
administration
to treat these sanctions as a day one
assault
on the independence of its foreign
policy by denouncing this
intimidation in the strongest possible
terms
but as the chinese communist party is
determined to prove
actions speak louder than words
so i also call upon president biden to
act reciprocally
by sanctioning chinese officials who are
responsible for this blackmail campaign
against his administration those
officials
shouldn't be able to fare it away their
fortunes in the u.s banking system
the way so many corrupt chinese
oligarchs do nor should their princeling
children get degrees from our top
universities
or internships at prestigious washington
think tanks
president biden should also refuse to
nominate for senior positions
individuals who are professionally or
financially entangled with china
who could be compromised by the mere
threat of sanctions
finally president biden should determine
whether chinese ambassador
suay tiankai was involved in these
sanctions and if so
he should be expelled immediately for
this egregious
effort to subvert american foreign
policy
and that's just for the short term
america must also begin to disentangle
our economy from china
to decouple our economies the chinese
communist party's sanctions
only pose a threat because american
society is so deeply compromised
by chinese influence american
corporations the big banks think tanks
universities
film studios even our sports leagues
even lebron james
are all addicted to chinese cash
they're all part of a new china lobby
that's deeply invested in the status quo
and thus hostile to any efforts to
redefine
u.s china relations in america's
interest
this lobby makes their money in china
they make their products in china
they've made their bed in china and now
they are
all vulnerable to pressure from the
chinese government
america hasn't been in a bind since our
earliest days
when our young republic was encircled by
hostile imperial powers
even during the cold war america had few
entanglements of the sort we faced today
the u.s had very little trade with the
russians
we competed in separate lanes like
runners in a race
the new cold war with china isn't so
orderly
communist china is wealthier and has
more people than did soviet russia
and their economies have become deeply
entangled
these new sanctions are just the latest
example of how that entanglement
threatens our security and prosperity
here's how the united states can beat
china in this strategic competition
first the united states should impose
restrictions on
inbound and outbound investment with
china
wall street has financed china's
industrial and technological development
for more than four decades and has
become compromised
for the bargain that has to end
second the united states should move
supply chains for critical goods
such as semiconductors and
pharmaceuticals out of china
and back to american soil china today
may be the so-called factory of the
world
but it was corporate america with its
army of bankers and lawyers and
consultants
who built that factory that's got to end
as well third the united states must
restrict the flow of knowledge and
advanced technology between our country
and china
american colleges universities and
research libraries are the finest
in the world but they allow chinese
nationals to participate
even in cutting-edge research with
military applications
and this research has an alarming
tendency
to end up in china and the weapons
fielded by the people's
liberation army against our own
troops that information pipeline
needs to be shut off and many of those
chinese nationals
need to go none of these steps will be
easy
but the chinese communist party's
punitive sanctions
against trump administration officials
and his blackmail campaign
against biden administration officials
demonstrate
that decoupling our economies is both
necessary
and urgent the communists in beijing
have lulled too many americans into
complacency and dependency
over the course of many years they now
intend to blackmail
even our government into inaction
so our intention must be different the
united states must break
free of chinese communist
suffocating grasp fight back
and win madam president yield before
senator from oklahoma is recognized
thank you
madam president first of all let me just
compliment my friend from arkansas in
the great remarks
people are not aware of the threats that
we're facing this country
and uh and we want to want to join him
and encouraging the
the new administration to understand and
address these threats
but um madam chair i
since last week there have been over 20
000 members of the national guard
stationed here at the capitol they're
here to
and have been here and are still here to
keep us
safe keep the members safe senators safe
staff press all of us we've seen some
people
speculating that maybe this was overkill
maybe we didn't really need this many
people here
and they're wrong because there was this
is a
nice successful inauguration a
successful
peaceful transfer of power because they
were there
and i made that very clear to the ones
i've been talking to in the field in the
last three days
i know firsthand that there are really
outstanding professionals
these guards we have about 400 guard
here from
the oklahoma national guard i visited
with them
uh i guess it was on wednesday in five
different groups i went around and
talked to them because they weren't all
in the same location
and uh we thanked them for their service
and the sacrifices they're making
long hours these guys are having long
hours that they have to and and
they're the best of the best many i saw
did
the the deployments in afghanistan
when i was talking to them they would
remember say
well senator inhofe i remember we were
together in afghanistan
we were together in ukraine these guys
that was 10 years ago
and they're still on the job working and
they're they're
i don't know what we could have done
without them so
in fact i asked several how many of you
in this group from oklahoma
in the guard have never been to
washington before
that this is your first trip more than
half of them had never been to
washington before so that was a
great opportunity for them too but i'm
really
humbled and grateful for what they're
doing for us and
i'm sure all of our colleagues are and
that's why i was so shocked and really
angry
last night and i picked it up on tv i
didn't know anything about it
when uh i heard that a that the guard
were being made to feel like they were
un welcomed
by some person in the capitol uh
police and then they were to take their
rest breaks
someplace else and actually sent to the
parking garage of all places
our guard members are being lodged in in
uh hotels
and they're working shifts uh 12 shifts
a day
long shifts on their feet so they need
to have rest breaks
they need to do the things and they
can't do that lying on the
in the in the center garage
so they have um the two hours on and one
hour off
plus time for eating and that type of
thing we can all agree
they should be comfortable on their
breaks a place to sit and lie down
eat and charge their batteries and
things they have to do talk to their
families
on home that's what they're supposed to
be doing and that's precisely where they
were
they're using the buildings here in the
capitol before they're made field
to feel unwelcome and pushed to the
garage without now that
i understand and i'm glad that they're
moved back in
and they're now well taken care of and
that's a good thing but they should
never have had to go through this
in the first place so what we did you
have to find out
you get to the bottom of it and that's
what we're doing now we're getting
answers
i called the acting chief of the capitol
police
this morning i called the general
general mcconville
general mcconville is the chief of the
staff at the army
and they're all working to find out how
this happened the acting chief
pittman says the guard were never asked
to leave
yesterday now i know that she believed
that but
several multiple members of the military
said no they were told to leave so
we know one thing that whether it's it
was confusion from the fog and the
fiction the
environment or whatever it was the
troops
didn't move on their own so they were
asked by somebody
this isn't a blame game i don't want to
but i do want to know what i have to
make sure it doesn't happen again
so this is what happened there was one
uniform
police officer who issued an order
without
authority or without going through the
chain of command
and i'm glad that the u.s capitol police
and the guard are
are talking and trying to figure this
out we are going to be able to identify
who that person was
we'll make that publicly but ultimately
one message for our national guard up
here
you are appreciated you are welcome you
are very very
we're very very grateful for the
sacrifices that you made
and uh if you're ever told at any point
that you need to vacate and don't have a
comfortable place
just go to russell 205 and i'll make
sure you'll be very comfortable in my
office
and i know that there's a bipartisan
outrages about this so
i think you'll have plenty of places to
rest you've done a great job
you'll be returning home soon and you'll
be able to say
job well done
thank you misery
are you on the floor
you
you
you
you
the senator from alaska is recognized
madam president i want to congratulate
now secretary of defense lloyd
austin on his confirmation
to be secretary of defense
i spoke yesterday about his
confirmation the two votes that had to
happen
i had the honor of introducing this
great american
at his confirmation hearing on the armed
services committee i served with him in
the military many years ago
and i think he's going to be an
important
addition to president biden's team
one of the things that we've been
working on over the last
several years is rebuilding our military
after drastic cuts
by
by the obama biden administration
hopefully we're not going to see that
again one of the reasons i was strongly
supporting
now secretary austin was because i
believe and i certainly hope this is the
correct belief and i got commitments
from him he won't
agree with that although i'm sure some
unfortunately in this body and others
in the bind administration are going to
agree with drastic cuts to the military
it'll hurt readiness
so one of the reasons that i think he's
going to be a good secretary
is not just his exceptional character
humility leadership
but because he knows what will happen if
there's
dramatic cuts like there was in the
second term of the obama biden
administration to our military not good
one things i had the opportunity to talk
to him about
one thing that's been a huge positive
for america
over the last decade for so many
reasons is that we become the world's
energy superpower again
like we were essentially during world
war ii what do i mean by that
prior to the pandemic we were the number
one producer of oil
yes people still need to use oil
i know some of my colleagues on this
body don't believe that but it's true
number one producer of natural gas clean
burning natural gas we're starting to
export it all around the world
number one producer of renewables so all
of the above america is the superpower
of energy
this is good it's great for the national
security of our nation
for a whole host of reasons general
austin understands that
secretary austin understands that it's
great for jobs
in the 2008-2009 recession
the number one sector of the economy
that got us out of the great recession
was
the energy sector in terms of gdp growth
and jobs it's great for the environment
why do i say that some people
tilt their heads it's great for the
environment because
in america certainly in my state alaska
we have the highest standards on the
environment of any place in the world by
far it's not even close
so if you need energy which you do
you should do it and produce it in the
place that respects the environment the
most not russia
not saudi arabia america alaska
it's good for energy security it's good
for manufacturing low-cost
natural gas throughout the country
and like i said madame madam president
it's really
good for jobs these are really good jobs
resource development jobs are really
good jobs
they support working families and the
middle class
everybody knows that
so that's a good thing that's happening
in the united states of america
there's some fringe groups that don't
like energy unfortunately some of my
colleagues
in the senate don't like hydrocarbons
but by the way as we became the world's
energy superpower our greenhouse gas
emissions decline
probably more than any other
industrialized economy in the world
why because natural gas is clean burning
so this is a win win win
win win on so many fronts
so here's what i'm speaking right now
because it's all at risk
it's all at risk
the first few days the new biden
administration
has seen an unprecedented assault
on resource development in
energy jobs an attack on men and women
working men and women
good wages produce really important
resources for this great nation and now
for other countries because we export a
lot of these
resources an assault
on good energy jobs good resource
development jobs
that have been the bedrock
of millions of middle class americans
for decades
four decades let me just give you an
example just in my state
everybody knows about anwar right this
body moved
in terms of legislation for leases we
did it the
right way law passed by the senate and
the house
signed by the president to move forward
on leases
first day on the job new president
decides he's going to suspend everything
with regard to anwar
okay that wasn't a surprise to be honest
but
of course it was a huge disappointment
not sure is legal
like i said we did it the legal way he's
doing the old-fashioned obama pen
and phone way probably a lot of
questionable legalities there so that's
one we were expecting that but here's
the other one madam
president we have another part of alaska
called the national petroleum reserve of
alaska set aside by congress
for oil and gas development not
controversial
we've been doing it for decades it was
originally called the naval petroleum
reserve
for america okay this is not
controversial
and we have a lot of energy projects
in the npra that are ongoing heck even
the obama biden administration allowed
us to
drill there because that's what congress
said for decades
and it's good for the country we need
energy
we need energy so if we need it
shouldn't we get it from america
shouldn't we get it from american
workers
better than getting it from russia so
the npra
is a really important area of america's
energy production in my state
national petroleum reserve of alaska
it's been that way for decades
so there's a moratorium on any more
permits
for energy production in the npra
yesterday i woke up to text messages
from alaskans
saying senator help us my little
company's going to go out of business
i've got to lay off a bunch of workers
workers who are doing what producing
american energy since when was that bad
mr president
since when was that bad
one more thing they say well it's only a
60-day moratorium
in alaska because we have the highest
standards in the world
on producing energy exploring for
energy we only do exploration
in the winter costs more for energy
companies
why do we do that because it's the high
standards that we have
highest standards of any place on the
planet earth
what do i mean by that we build what are
called ice roads
and ice pads on the tundra
when we explore and when we drill so
that means
we just do it in the winter you build
these ice roads and ice pads it costs a
lot of money
and when you move equipment across the
tundra on ice
you drill for thr you drill for three
months
and when the winter's over you move it
off the ice melts and there's not
one tiny impact it's called zero impact
z
drilling and exploration i used to be in
charge of this in alaska i'm very
familiar with it
high standards on the planet so if you
put a 60-day moratorium on drilling in
the npra
guess what you lose the whole season
you lose the whole season so that's what
the biden administration did yesterday
and i literally had people back home in
my great state
calling frantically saying hundreds if
not
thousands of jobs are at risk that was
day two
of the biden administration let's crush
every single energy job
in america why i don't know why
i don't know why since when is it bad to
produce energy for
your fellow americans we need it we have
the highest standards in the world
these are great middle class jobs
but day one in this administration
they're attacking
men and women
who produce energy for this great nation
shameful now it's not just me madam
president who's a little bit upset you
can tell i'm a little bit upset
the keystone pipeline was cancelled
again
again no idea why they would do that
there's nothing about climate change as
a matter of fact that
pipeline was going to be all union jobs
and they had they had it developed and
worked on in a way that was going to be
emission neutral so here's the
head of the laborers international union
of america
lyuna the laborers terry o'sullivan he's
a great american
i know him well his father was a marine
who served in the chosen reservoir
during the korean war
i'd like to submit this for the record
madam president
without objection this is a statement by
terry o'sullivan
the biden administration's decision to
cancel the keystone xl pipeline permit
on day one of his presidency is both
insulting
and disappointing to the thousands of
hard-working lyuna members
who will lose good-paying jobs
middle-class families supporting jobs
by the way lyon is the largest labor
union in the construction
largest labor construction unit in
america
500 000 members
blocking this hundred percent union
project and pandering to environmental
extremists
a thousand union jobs will immediately
vanish
and 10 000 additional jobs will be gone
forever
that's day one this isn't me talking
the senator from alaska this is the head
of lyuna
we support the president's campaign to
quote build back better
but for union members affected by this
decision there are no renewable energy
jobs that come even close to replacing
the wages
and benefits the keystone xl project
would have provided
killing good union jobs on day one with
nothing to replace them is not building
back better this is
again terry o'sullivan head of lyonna
another statement madam president i'd
like to submit for the record this is
mark mcmanus general president united
association of
union plumbers and pipefitters they were
going to build
the pipeline keystone pipeline too just
like the lyuna members
without objection
quote in revoking this permit the biden
administration has chose to listen
to the voices of fringe activists
instead of union members
in the american consumer on day one
let me be clear when built with union
labor
by the men and women of the united
association mr mcmanus union
pipelines like keystone xl remain the
safest and most efficient modes of
transportation in the world
sadly the biden administration has now
put thousands of union workers
out of work
so madam president let me close with
this
there are a number of senators who want
to meet directly with the president
on this issue by the way when they made
these announcements about alaska
no one from the abide administration
reached out no one called me no one
called senator murkowski no one called
congressman young
you'd think if they were going to just
kill hundreds if not thousands of jobs
in your state
that somebody would have reached out to
us
i just spent the last week working hard
to make sure
the biden administration secretary
defense got confirmed
i probably worked harder than any other
senator in this body on that issue
i did that because i think it's going to
be good for the military and good for
america
but we're trying we're trying
i haven't heard from one person on the
buy administration so a number of us are
going to try and request a meeting
with the president the president
talks a lot about his blue collar
background
great but guess what
the president is killing blue-collar
jobs
right now right now
by the thousands and a lot of them are
in my state
i hope somebody
in the new administration is listening
to this
i hope he realizes what he's doing
we're in his pandemic
our economy needs to grow we have high
unemployment
and the idea that you would start your
administration by
targeting the men and women who have
built this great nation
who have good paying jobs is astounding
to me
mr president and i'm not talking about
the president of the senate madam
president i'm talking about the
president united states you need to
listen to us
this is not a good start you talked in
your inauguration about
putting yourself in other people's shoes
i'll help you put yourself in the shoes
of the energy
workers in america who you are crushing
right now
put yourself in their shoes and maybe
rethink these crazy
crazy policies that are only harming
americans
throughout the country i yield the floor
madam president i know the absence of a
quorum the clerk will call the world
miss baldwin